[Music]
is kris jenner really running for office
tune in because you never know what's
going to happen
well not exactly but chris is hopping on
the hashtag crist train pulling off a
presidential prank
[Music]
yeah the mama jerk got us good
announcing on tick tock her run for
president in 2024 with convincing
campaign art caption i'm excited to
announce
we definitely got crisp the viral trend
shows a fake video but get this to full
viewers a throwback clip of chris
dancing pops up proving it's all a hoax
ding ding ding ding
yeah the kardashian jinner crew can be
quite the pranksters as we've seen on
their old show keeping up with the
kardashians remember when chloe and kim
bought their mom her favorite dessert i
love that cake give me a hug
okay hey what's wrong why do you want to
hug me
huh what
is wrong with you
what the hell are you doing read this
sweet message
how does payback taste
tastes like sweet revenge but it gets
better i don't know how you're gonna top
that let me jog your memory here
kourtney kardashian put out a poll on
twitter for potential pranks and well
let's just say things took a turn this
one's good this one's good
it's pretty solid one of court's
followers suggested putting chocolate
near kendall's bum so it looks like she
woke up with poop in her pants
what
i tell you
what is it
we wanted you to shart yourself
we tweeted what can we do to a sleeping
person and everyone everyone said to put
chocolate in their background
and leave it to courtney's ex scott
disick to never miss out on the family
shenanigans i mean who doesn't love a
good prank call
auntie chris it's me
[Music]
call again
hello
auntie chris why do you always hang up
on me
who would you think it is it's me todd
graves
it's the only number i had for you
a lot has changed since then but the
kardashian jenner crew still has a good
sense of humor
it's never a dull moment
on the family's new hulu series the
kardashians there's a little less fun in
games and more real life moments as they
navigate co-parenting and scandal this
season never go against the family
never go against the family
when e.t spoke to the reality family
back in april chris revealed fans would
get a behind-the-scenes look of their
daily lives
the episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and i think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes
[Music]
you